معنا من القدس مراسله الجزيره نجوان سمري
اذا نجوان هذا المسير
الاحتجاجي الذي ظل يوما كاملا في تلبيب
ايضا وصلت الى الى حيفا الى الى القدس كيف
تتابع هذه الجماهير ايضا ما يرد في وسائل
الاعلام خاصه هذه
الفيديوهات التي تثير غموضا حول مسير
الاسرى الاساس محمد ما يزيد ربما من ضغط
الشارع الاسرائيلي على الحكومه ونرى بان
هناك تصاعد واضح في الحراك المطالب بال
العمل الفوري من اجل استعاده الاسرى
الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في غزه ولكن ليس
فقط وانما الى تحويل هذه القضيه الى
اولويه من اولويات مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي
في كل الحرب على غزه وايضا ان تبادر
الحكومه الاسرائيليه ومجلس الحرب تحديدا
الى وضع مقترح اسرائيلي من اجل صفقه تبادل
لسرى مقترح يكون قابلا للتنفيذ وفقا
ل العائلات الاسرى وعدم الانتظار فقط الى
مقترحات تاتي من الدول الوسطاء وانما ان
تبادر اسرائيل لمره واحده وان تضع منحى
جديد لاحد المقترحات من اجل الافراج عن
الاسرى وهذا يحدث
ربما ضمن تغييرات نشهدها على مطالبات
العائلات ومن يدعمهم في اسرائيل من اجل
الافراج عن الاسرى الاسرائيليين المحتجزين
في غزه في البدايه كانت طيله الوقت هذه
العائلات وهذا التيار الاحتجاجي من اجل
اعاده المحتجزين كان ربما يقتصر فقط على
المطالبه من اجل استعاده الاسرى والضغط
على الحكومه ل ابرام صفقه تباد لكن من
الواضح انه في الايام الاخيره الماضيه
وبعد مرور 100 يوم ودون ان تحرز هذه
الحكومه ومجلس الحرب اي تقدم في هذا
الاتجاه هناك ضغوط اكبر وهناك ايضا
مطالبات بتحميل المسؤوليه للحكومه
الاسرائيليه بالاخفاق من جهه عن صد هجوم
السابع من اكتوبر ولكن ايضا عن الاخفاق في
التقدم في هذا المسار من اجل اعاده
المحتجزين ونرى ان الغضب في الشارع
الاسرائيلي ولدى العائلات بدا يزداد اكثر
فاكثر ويطالبون ايضا بتنحي هذه الحكومه
وليس فقط بالعمل من اجل استعاده الاسر
شكرا جزيلا لك نجوان سمري من القدس